protecting your money has been a big
topic of discussion as of late whether
it's making sure your financial
institution is safe and insured or
protecting yourself from scammers I
spoke with president and CEO Scott a
articles to find out how Silver State
Schools Credit Union the sponsors of
this segment is protecting their members
I am talking to the president and CEO of
Summer State Schools Credit Union which
I am a proud member Scott a Arcos hi
Scott how are you good how are you doing
Mercedes we are so great today and I'm
glad I have this opportunity to talk to
you because there is something very
topical going on with banks right now
and I have to ask you there is so much
discussion right now about the safety
and the soundness of member deposits in
financial institutions our Silver State
schools credit union members deposits
safe and insured absolutely Mercedes and
it's this as you said this is a great
topic for right now and very timely so
Silver State Schools Credit Union as you
know has proudly served its member
owners for over 72 years now and we're
now at over 61 000 members strong we're
well capitalized we're financially
strong in all regards and most
importantly Our member deposits are
insured with American Share insurance
I'm also known as ASI they're a trusted
sound and highly respected private
insurance company that was established
in 1974. in addition Silver State
Schools Credit Union participates in
their excess share insurance program
which means each member is further
insured up to 500 000 per account now
what about if a member has say a million
dollars with silver state Schools Credit
Union is only 500 000 insured no nope
and and that's a great question Mercedes
well one of the great benefits of
offering privately held insurance for
member deposits is the coverage ASI and
ESI provides per account so an account
is defined as a savings account a
checking account a money market account
uh certificates account and even
retirement savings accounts so all
server State Schools Credit Union
Deposit accounts are insured up to five
hundred thousand dollars each for
example a member can have a five hundred
thousand dollar bill balance in the
savings the checking the money market
and certificate of deposit account and
all two million dollars will be fully
insured and that's as opposed to an FDIC
or ncua insured Credit Union uh that uh
that may be only insured to 250 000 all
told now speaking talking of protecting
your deposits protecting your money
scammers continue to scam they target
people how can the community protect
themselves I tell everybody to use the
common sense kind of filter and also
look and see where it's coming from and
we remind everyone in the community to
never ever ever ever I can't I can't
underline that more share their personal
identification uh information with
anybody that they don't personally know
um and that's via text web page or phone
call Silver State Schools Credit Union
will never ever reach out to anybody to
specifically ask for the personal
identification information and so so we
we don't ever want you to give that up
there they're out there and they're
that's what they're trying to get
thank you to Silver State Schools Credit
Union for sponsoring this segment visit
silverstatecu.com or call
702-733-8820 for more information we'll
be right back